TODAY- WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
ITEMS- ON THE AGENDA I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT ITEM NUMBER
THREE ACR TWENTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER GIPSON IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SO WE'LL JUST THE
HEARING. UNLESS THERE'S AN
EXTRACTION ITEMS ONE INTO-
AGAIN REMINDER OUR COMMITTEE
RULES ARE SUCH THAT WE ASK THAT
EACH- WHEN WE HAVE
PRESENTATIONS THAT- OF THE- PRO
CUTS SIDE VIEW HAVE- TWO
WITNESSES THREE MINUTES MAXIMO
PIECE FOR SIX MINUTES ALTHOUGH
IF YOU HAVE THREE WITNESSES YOU
CAN SPLIT THE OTHER WAY. AND
THEN SAME WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND WE ASK THAT PEOPLE TRIED IT
HERE TO PLEASE AT HERE TO THOSE
RULES AND- WITH THAT- WE WILL
FIRST CONVENE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS- HERE FOR A QUORUM. AND
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR EIGHTY
SIX BY CENTER BATES AND I DO
SEE CENTER BATES HERE WELCOME.
WELL THANK YOU I CHAIRMAN I AND
DOCTOR POUND ON SOME. GREAT TO
BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON CONTRA
PERCENT OF MY ON. BILL ON OUR
RECOVERY RESIDENCES SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX. I IT DOES PRO KIBET
COMMERCIALLY OPERATED RECOVERY
RESIDENCES FROM ENGAGING IN
PATIENT BROKERING. AND AS A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY
FOR ANY VIOLATION. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT ON SENATOR LARA.
THAT PROHIBITS THE PRACTICE OF
PATIENT BROKERING FOR LICENSED
ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY OR TREATMENT
FACILITIES OWNERS AND OPERATORS
OF AN R. T. OFF. IN ANY PERSON
THAT WORKS IN A- RECOVERY
TREATMENT FACILITY HOWEVER THIS
BILL DID NOT APPLY TO RECOVERY
RESIDENCES ANNOUNCE ALSO. HAS
WE KNOW SOBER LIVING HOMES. SB
FOUR EIGHTY SIX WILL SIMPLY ADD
COMMERCIALLY OPERATED RECOVERY
RESIDENCES TO THE LIST OF
ENTITIES THAT CANNOT GIVE OR
RECEIVE ANYTHING OF VALUE. THE
REFERRAL OF AN INDIVIDUAL
SEEKING ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG
ABUSE RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
SERVICES. GET OUT THE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY FOR
VIOLATIONS WELL AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT PROTECTS
INDIVIDUALS AND RECOVERY
RESIDENCES FOR REGULATION BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. IT COULD NOT. HAVE
BEEN THE INTENT. THE PDA TO
ALLOW FOR ASIA BROKERING TO
OCCUR IN UPPER LIP HOMES. ARE
THERE IS A PREDATORY PRACTICES
LED TO MANY WE ARE VERY.
FORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
PEOPLE LINCOLN NUCLEAR
ADDICTION AND KIRBY AS WE A AND
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED I
NEIGHBORHOOD. ALSO THE PREDATOR
PRACTICE TO REALLY NEEDS BOB
AND I BELIEVE THIS IS ONE. AREA
THAT HAS KIND OF FALL INTO THE
CRACKS. AS YOUR CENTER MORE
WHAT CAN I. DO IF THOSE ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. IN
CREATING ENTERS AND
REQUIREMENTS. NEED TO SOBER
LIVING HOMES WELL THE DISCUSS.
CONTINUE CAP. AND TAKE A STAND
TODAY AND PREVENT INDIVIDUALS
WITH ADDICTION FROM TREATED.
INCOME PRODUCING COMMODITIES.
THE BILL WILL MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THE STANDARDS THAT WERE
SET IN PLACE BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILL ALSO
APPLY. TO RECOVERY RESIDENCES
THAT ARE COMMERCIALLY OPERATED.
THANK YOU FOR ON YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY AND WE DO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU BUT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT A YEAR MAYBE THEY HAVE
A RIGHT OKAY. HE OF THE WHICH
THE TESTIFYING COME BEFORE A TO
ME TOO OKAY CONNIE CONNIE
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI SHERRY DAVIS CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS IN PROFESSIONALS WHO
WERE IN IT WIENER POSITION- WE
LOVE THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL WE
JUST FEEL THAT THE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR A FIND SHOULD
HAVE SOME LATITUDE TO IT SO
THAT THE DEPARTMENT COULD
ASSESS  PROPORTIONAL SANCTION
AGAINST THIS ACTIVITY INSTEAD
OF AN AUTOMATIC FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR FIGURE OF FINE AND WE
ALSO OBJECT TO THE USE OF THE
WORD COMMERCIAL BECAUSE IT
MIGHT CREATE ZONING PROBLEMS
FOR A RECOVERY RESIDENCES BY
CREATING A NEW DEFINITION THAT
MAKES THEM SEEM MORE AS A
BUSINESS IN AN OPERATION THAT A
HOME. THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT SEE
NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HE
WAS TO COME UP TO THE TABLE.
AND WHILE THE WITNESSES COME AT
THE TABLE I WOULD ASK THAT
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WE ARE ONE SHORT OF A
QUORUM SO HE COULD MAKE YOUR
WAY OVER HERE AT APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU YES WITH THIS IN
OPPOSITION DOCTORPAN- MEMBERS
KERR CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- WE WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY WITH THAT WE CERTAINLY-
OPPOSE THE IDEA. OF PATIENT
BROKERING IN THAT ODIOUS
PRACTICES HAS IT'S BEEN USED
AND PRACTICES AND PRACTICE- IN
PARTICULARLY IN VARIOUS AREAS
OF THE STATE SO WE APPRECIATE
THE- MEMBERS- INTEREST IN
ATTEMPTING TO DEAL WITH THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WE THINK- ON-
THE- ON. THE BILL- STEPPING
INTO- THE RECOVERY HOMES REALLY
TWO THINGS ARE- THAT WE THINK
ARE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS- WITH
THAT AND PARTICULARLY THAT THEY
ARE COVERED BY THE- FHA. IN
PARTICULAR AND SO THESE BECOME
RESTRICTIONS AND REGULATIONS ON
THESE- GROUP HOMES- ONE PIECE
THAT WE FIND TO A PARTICULARLY
TROUBLING ON THIS IS IN APPLIES
TO- COMMERCIAL. RESIDENTS AS
WELL AND THAT'S ANOTHER CLEAR
AND APPLYING- BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SAYS THAT- HOUSING ACT APPLIES
EQUALLY TO- COMMERCIAL RECAP
HOMES AS WELL AS- THOSE THAT
ARE NOT TOO WE JUROR. BUT ON
THE. OKAY ABOVE TAKE THEIR
OPPOSITION- TESTIMONIAL ICE TO
SEE WE HAVE A- QUORUM SO
SURGERY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AM I HERE ENDS HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE GROWTH.
GROWTH HERE HER TADO. HURTADO
HERE LEYVA LABOR HERE MITCHELL
MONNING RUBIO. OKAY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM OKAY FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
AND FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY ARSINOE THEIR
TESTIMONY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GROVE
OKAY- SURVEYS I DID I DO HAVE A
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT- RELEASED THE QUESTION TO
ASK YOU SO THE- AN ANALYSIS AND
ALSO THE OPPOSITIONISTS
TESTIFIED THERE'S A CONCERN
ABOUT- THE FHA RULES
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT I MEAN.
A YOU TALK ABOUT A COMMERCIAL.
OPERATED RECOVERY RESIDENTS-
BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE FHA
SAYS IS THAT I MEAN THESE ARE
NOT LICENSED FACILITIES- THESE
ARE RESIDENCES RIGHT AND- SO
OUR CURRENT LAW CURRENTLY
ALLOWS FOR EXAMPLE IF A
LICENSED TREATMENT FACILITY. IS
MAKING PAYMENTS LET'S SAY TO A
LANDLORD OR WHOEVER IS RUNNING
SUCH A YELLOW- ZILLION IS
MAKING PAYMENTS- THAT THAT IN
WE CATCH THEM DOING THAT- AN
ORDER OF EXCHANGE OF PATIENTS
THEN THE FACILITY THAT'S CTION
THAT FACILITY CAN LOSE OUR
LICENSE AND BASICALLY BE
EXCLUDED FROM BUSINESS RIGHT
SELLERS THERE ISA MECHANISM
TO. ADDRESS TO TRY TO PUNISH
THOSE WHO ENGAGE IN THIS
PATIENT BROKERING ON THE FLIP
SIDE THOUGH IS THAT AND I KNOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE HOME SIDE
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THE WAY THE
FHA IS STRUCTURED. WE CAN'T. I
MEAN IT'S A IT'S A LIVING
SITUATION IT'S- IT AND SO WE
CAN'T DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THAT- SO. SO WHAT'S YOUR I MEAN
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE AS
RESOLVING THAT ISSUE IN YOUR
CURRENT BILL BECAUSE I THINK AT
LEAST THE WAY I'VE SEEN IT IS
THAT. THE DOES RUNNING CONFLICT
WITH THE FHA. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION. SENATOR POUND
ARE I THINK WHAT WE HAVE BEEN I
THINK WE'VE ALL BEEN STRUGGLING
WITH THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN TWENTY YEARS OF FILE
LEGISLATURA LAWS PROPOSED HERE
TO TRY TO CURB WHAT SEEMS TO BE
ON I'M JUST GOING TO SAY IT THE
WAY I SEE IT I ABSOLUTE ABUSE
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE RECOVERING
FROM ONE SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO
ANOTHER AW SOMETHING NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH THE ONES THAT ARE
CONSIDERED GROUP HOMES THEY
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT DID
MANAGE TO. SLIDE AMONGST ALL OF
THE REGULATIONS BECAUSE A SOBER
LIVING HOME CAN HAVE MORE THAN
SIX PEOPLE I THINK THAT THAT
WAS THE CONCERN ORIGINALLY
PEOPLE THOUGHT- A SOBER LIVING
HOME YOU CAN ONLY HAVE SIX ONE
NO BECAUSE IT'S A GROUP HOME IS
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH A
PARTICULAR SUBSTANCE ABUSE THE
COULD BE ALCOHOL DRUGS WHATEVER
THAT COME TOGETHER TO LIVE
TOGETHER AS A GROUP. SO WHAT'S
MISSING CLEARLY IS TO HAVE
THESE SET OFFFOR THOSE WHO ARE
DISABLED AFFLICTED WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE COMPARED TO
THOSE WHO ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED ALL WHO ARE DISABLED
TO PHYSICALLY- LAWS LIKE OUR
ELDERS SENIORS ALL OF THOSE
OTHER- PROTECTED CLASSES IS
QUITE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ARENA. AND THE SOBER
LIVING HOMES ARE BAD ACTORS
LET'S SAY DISCOVERED THAT THEY
CAN WEAVE THEIR WAY THROUGH
THAT IS STILL GO OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND BASICALLY RECRUIT
ALL THOSE ARE LIVING ON THE
STREET OBVIOUSLY ENGAGE AND
THEN REFER THEM FOR A SOBER
LIVING HOME- DIRECTLY TO A
TREATMENT FACILITY. SO THERE'S
ANOTHER CHAIN WE STOPPED AT THE
R. T. OUT. FROM OB RECRUITING
INTO THAT WE DID OT STOP AT
THE OTHER END SO THEY'RE COMING
IN THE OTHER WAY THEY'RE COMING
INTO GROUP HOMES ALCOHOL AND ON
A MISS WHATEVER. WILLING THEIR
TO RECRUIT PEOPLE AND THEY'RE
GOING INTO IT IS JUST. A
RECOVERY RESIDENTS WHICH HAS
NO- MANDATORY- RESTRICTION ON
NUMBER IN THE HOME NO TREATMENT
CAN BE GIVEN YET. THEY'RE
COMING IN THAT WAY AND THEY'RE
NOT ACTUALLY. I THINK SOLVING
THE PROBLEM THAT PEOPLE HAVE
THE REASON THEY GATHER TOGETHER
SO WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY. AND I
DO THINK THAT THE- THE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN OFFERED OF THE
DISCUSSION OF COMMERCIALLY- RUN
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT WOULD
AFFECT THE ZONING ISSUE THAT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD
RESTRICTED BECAUSE NOW IT'S
COMMERCIAL. AND MAKE IT GO TO
SOME OTHER PART OF THE CITY AND
THEY WANT THESE HOMES TO BE IN
A IN A NEIGHBORHOOD. SO PEOPLE
ARE SURROUNDED WITH WHAT IS
LACKEY HOME QUOTE UNQUOTE HI TO
RECOVER AND BECOME PART OF. THE
COMMUNITY AND CERTAINLY KICK
THEIR HABIT WHATEVER IDEA SO I
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEMS BUT I
DON'T THINK WE CAN CONTINUE TO
KICK THE CAN DOWN THE- ROAD
WHEN YOU NOW HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY BEING PRESENTED.
ARE THAT THEY COME IN THE OTHER
WAY BECAUSE WE SHUT OFF. YOU
KNOW THE OF THE ROAD AND THREE
THE RTO SPENT WE STILL HAVE
THIS OPEN DOOR ON A SOBER
LIVING HOME WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT BOB CERTAINLY I
WOULD BE VERY PLEASED TO TAKE
ON. THE MINNESOTA BEEN
SUGGESTED BY THOSE WHO ARE.
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS I THINK
THAT'S A START IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT T<c.cyan> LEAVE IT TO</c>
THE COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS AND-
YOU KNOW. FIND A. PUT AWAY OR
SEND ME OUT TO DO SOME MORE
WORK. FIND IT BECAUSE I HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS SINCE I WAS
ELECTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
I HAVE A FEW MORE YEARS TO KEEP
AT IT. SO I WILL CERTAINLY BE
DOING THAT. OKAY YES ARE
NECESSARILY A- THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES- I DO AGREE WITH
YOU WE DON'T WANT ANYONE UP
PUSHING SOMEONE INTO A FACILITY
AND THEN RECEIVING MONEY FOR
THAT OR ANYTHING OF VALUE- I DO
HAVE A LITTLE ISSUE WITH A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE I
JUST FEEL LIKE THAT IS WAY WAY
WAY TOO MUCH I MEAN WE JUST HAD
A BILL LAST YEAR WHERE. IF
UNDER STAFFING RATIOS ARE MET
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY DIE- IT
IN THE FIRST FIVE VIOLATIONS
FIFTEEN THOUSAND THE NEXT
FOUNDATION IS THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT FIFTY THOUSAND IS TERRIBLY
HIGH MY OTHER QUESTION IS I
DON'T BELIEVE THE SOBER LIVING
HOMES ARE REGULATED BY. DH CS.
OKAY BUT DH CS IS THE ONE WHO
WOULD BE FINING THEM. THAT
SEEMS THAT SEEMS A LITTLE THE
THEY WOULD BE THE ENFORCEMENT
OUR HOUSE THEY ARE FOR THE RTF
OKAY THEY WOULD HAVE THAT ALL
RESPONSIBILITY AT ALL OR WHEN
SOMEONE ACTUALLY COMPLAINED SIR
OUR- OFFENSE A COMPLAINT ABOUT
ONE THAT'S OPERATING THAT WAY
OKAY I WONDER IF THEY ARE THE
BEST AGENCY TO BE THE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SINCE THEY
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO CONTROL OVER
THOSE HOMES. I DON'T KNOW THAT
I HAVE A SUGGESTION FOR A
BETTER ONE BUT- I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING-
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU
KEEP WORKING ON IT BECAUSE I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT LIKE IN ITS
CURRENT FORM TODAY- BUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF THE-BILL AND MAYBE WE CAN KEEP
MARK. WORKING ON AND FIGURE OUT
A WAY FORWARD. QUESTION OKAY.
AND AGAIN CENTER BATES I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS
I KNOW THE YOU KNOW WITH HER.
EARLIER IN THE STATE TIME SINCE
THEN TO TODAY UNFORTUNATELY
AND- NOT SHUTTERS SUFFICIENT
PROGRESS A- YES AND I SUPPOSE
THIS IN THE BEGINNING THAT THE
CHALLENGE. IS I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY IS THAT WE CAN'T-
BASICALLY SAY WELL THESE ARE
SOBER LIVING HOMES AND THESE
ARE. OTHER HOUSES RIGHT SO
WHATEVER RULE WE APPLY HAS TO
APPLY ACROSS ALL LIVING
SITUATIONS THAT'S WHAT THE FHA
SAYS AND I'M AFRAID THIS BILL I
THINK THAT IS ALSO SOME ISSUES
ABOUT LIKE THE AMOUNT I THINK
THE FINES BUT EXCESSIVE AND
SARAH. AT CURRENT LAW DOES
ALLOW US TO GO SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF THERE'S A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITY WHICH IS
LICENSED BY DTS. THEN WE FIND
OUT THAT THEY ARE- MAKING OR
ACCEPTING PAYMENTS. FROM OTHERS
FOR PATIENT BROKERING. THAT'S
THE ENTITY THAT IS ACTUALLY
LICENSED AND CAN BE PUNISHED
AND HAVE THE LICENSE THE
REMOVED SO NUTS BECAUSE IT
TAKES TWO TO TANGO RIGHT SO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE- YET OF SOMEONE
WHO'S SENDING THE MINES ON
ACCEPTING THE MONEY SO- SO
FORTUNATELY THAT IS EXISTING
LAW I THINK THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE ANY APPROACH ON THE
HOME SIDE WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THINGS THAT APPLY EQUALLY
TO. ALL HOUSES. OR POTENTIALLY
BE YOU KNOW- IF THERE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT NOT AS A HOME
RIGHT BECAUSE- AS MUCH AS WE
MIGHT WANT TO STAY SOBER LIVING
HOMES IN ANY TRIED TO
COMMERCIAL BUT THEN IT PAYS
REYES THAT DISTINCTION ABOUT
WILL THAT BY DEFINITION WHAT'S
COMMERCIAL RIGHT IF YOU'RE
RENTING IT TO PEOPLE DOES THAT
AUTOMATICALLY MAKE A
COMMERCIAL- BUT I JUST RENTING
TO SOMEONE WHO IS RE AIRING AT-
DOES THAT AUTOMATICALLY MAKE
YOU KNOW- AND HOW MANY OF THEM
HAVE TO THE INTERNET SITUATION-
SO. I DO THINK THE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUE THAT IS ON STONE RESOLVED
IN THIS BILL IS IT'S- CONFLICT
WITH SIR FEDERAL LAW AND ALSO
CIVIL RIGHTS ABOUT SAYING THAT.
AGAIN THESE ARE ON LICENSE
FACILITIES SO THE PART OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU CAN TAKE AWAY THEIR
LICENSE- THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHO THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO THEY'RE NOT REGISTERED
AND I KNOW PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT
BUT AGAIN THESE ARE HOMES.
THESE ARE NOT TREATED AS SOON
AS THE TIP OVER INTO BEING A
TREATMENT FACILITY. THEN THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR THAT RATE
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY GO AFTER SO
IF SOMEONE IS. TREATING IS
ENGAGING IN TREATMENT. WE CAN
THEN- GO OVER TO THEM FOR BEING
UNLICENSED AND PUNISH THEM FOR
THAT IF THEY MAKE PAYMENTS TO
IN ESSENCE FACILITY AND WE CAN
GO AFTER THE LICENSE FACILITY
ITSELF. TO SAY WHY ARE YOU
ACCEPTING PAYMENTS YOU SHUT UP
PATIENT PROGRAM SHOULD NOT BE
ACCEPTING OR GRANT GIVING
PAYMENTS TO PEOPLE. TO ANYBODY
FOR PATIENTS RIGHT SO- SO WE DO
HAVE THINGS IN PLACE MAYBE
THERE'S THINGS WE CAN TWEAK
ABOUT THAT ARE THINGS WE CAN DO
TO HELP SUPPORT- TO PROVIDE
MORE RESOURCES FOR ENFORCEMENT
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY ET TO
THAT- SO WE DO HAVE TOOLS TO DO
THAT. MAYBE YOU CAN FEEL WAYS
DANCE THOSE BUT I AM AFRAID
THAT THE WAY THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY IT'S STILL. AND FORTY
RUNS OF ALL OF. WHEN HOUSING
WILL SENSE FORTUNATE. NOT A
SPORT. BECAUSE OF THAT BUT I DO
HOPE THAT AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
WHILE WE CAN TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
OTHER MECHANISMS. WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE- HOW DO WE MAKE OUR
CURRENT MECHANISM EITHER MORE
EFFECTIVE ARE THINGS WE CAN
ADJUST THAT TO TRY JUST. THE
VERY REAL PROBLEM THAT YOU
SENIOR COMMUNITY GOT THE
COMMITTEES TO SEE- ALL RIGHT.
SO YES GROVE. I JUST WANNA
PLEDGES FOR BRINGING THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION FORWARD AND I
KNOW THAT IT WAS CREATIVE. FOR
YOU TO GO AROUND THIS MECHANISM
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IN THE
PAST- PREVIOUS YEARS
LEGISLATION HAS. BROUGHT FOR TO
THE LICENSOR. NEW SINCE IN
EFFECT ON THESE ONES. AS DOCTOR
AT THE CHAIRED MENTION. AND IT
WAS DEFEATED IT STOPPED AND SO.
I APPLAUD YOU FOR STILL TRYING
TO ASSESS ISSUE IN MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T. AND SHIVERS
BARTER TREATED OR SOLD LIKE.
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT'S GOING
ON IN THESE PARTICULAR
FACILITIES SO I THANK YOU FOR
DOING AND LOOKING FOR NEW IN.
WAITED. OUTSIDE THE BOX KING IN
ORDER TO TRY TO SOLVE THE. IT'S
CHARGING HILLOCK INDIA LICENSOR
BUT AGAIN IT WAS KILLED LAST
TIME BECAUSE IT BUDGET. THE
STATE SAID THEY NEEDED WHAT TO
ENTER NEW POSITIONS IN ORDER
TO. EXECUTE THAT SO BUT I
PLEDGE YOU FOR THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX. THANK YOU OKAY SIR YES
CENTER GONZALEZ. YES I JUST TO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AS WELL I
KNOW THIS IS. BEING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ONE BIG ISSUE
CERTAINLY- BUT I TO YOU KNOW
THINK THAT THIS NEEDS A LOT
MORE WORK- ALSO WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN FIGURING OUT HOW
IF THERE IS A THRESHOLD HOW DO
WE GET THOSE. LIVING FACILITIES
TO BECOME A CERTIFIED IF THEY
ARE AND THAT THAT BRINGS SO I
DON'T KNOW MAYBE THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON IF THERE'S BEEN ANY
DATA BROUGHT BACK FROM SB.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT FROM THE-
R. T. ASKS TO SEE IF THERE'S- I
DON'T KNOW ANY SORT OF DATA
THAT COULD BE BROUGHT BACK- AND
SIMILAR TO THE DISCUSSION WE
HAD ON THE GRAVELY DISABLED-
ISSUE I KNOW THAT THAT'S GOING
THROUGH AN AUDIT CURRENTLY BUT
PERHAPS THAT COULD BE ANOTHER
AVENUE AS WELL TO FIGURE OUT.
AND ALTHOUGH AND MAYBE THERE'S
SOME SORT OF STATE CONNECTION
THAT THEY HAVE OF SOME SORT OR
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DO TO PROVIDE MORE DATA TO.
HELP IN IN GETTING THESE FOLKS
LICENSED. AND UP TO PAR SO JUST
SOME IDEAS OUT THERE BUT THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU. NO ONE
ELSE OKAY. SO I TO WANNA THANK
YOU I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT.
WHEN THE BIG CHALLENGES IS
THAT. WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT SOBER
LIVING HOMES AS THERE'S NO
TREATMENTS IT'S SIMPLY PLACE
WHERE THEY LIVE. AND I THINK WE
JUST KIND OF THAT. THAT AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE HAVEN'T THAT'S
WHY WE WITH THE SEAT BELT
LEGISLATION HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
PUT IN PLACE TO LICENSE THEM.
OR NOT IT IS SOON AS THEY START
DOING ANYTHING BEYOND PEOPLE
LIVING THERE. AND THAT TIPS
INTO A WHOLE DIFFERENT ATEGORY
AND THEY ARE HAVE TO BE LICENSE
AND SO FORTH BUT IT. IT'S JUST.
BUT IT'S A GROUP OF PEOPLE
LIVING TOGETHER WE CAN'T
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST A GROUP OF
PEOPLE LIVING TOGETHER AND
ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE LIVING.
CHOOSING TO LIVE TOGETHER AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
WERE. STILL WRESTLING WITH. BUT
WITH THAT I ALSO DO WANT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST THANK
YOU THE DISCUSSION I DO I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A PATH.
THAT THEY'RE JUST. NOT READ. IT
SO NO FLORIDA THE STATE OF
FLORIDA HAS. A LOT OF WORK IN
THE NOW DO YOU HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT ON WHAT'S DEFINED AS
A- RECOVERY RESIDENTS
UNLICENSED SO WE'LL KEEP
WORKINGON IT. AND I THINK-
MAYBE ON CERTAINLY AND THE NEXT
A YEAR. HOPEFULLY WILL FIND AN
ANSWER AND- I WILL CERTAINLY BE
AUTHOR OR CO AUTHOR WHEN IT.
EMERGES WHEN IT REVEALS ITSELF
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
DISCUSSION. APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU TO REMOTE CENTER
BATES- THE- I JUST ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE I SHOULD DO THAT RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT A SERVICE
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND IT'S
BEEN THAT AS BEFORE SIX EIGHTY
SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS REFER
TO THE COMMISSION
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S BEEN- MOVED
BY SENATOR GROVE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND NO
AND NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ NO
GROWTH. GROWTH I HER TATO. HER
TITLE NO LEYVA LEYVA NO
MITCHELL. MORNING RUBIO. THE
CURRENT CODE IS ONE FOUR WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND- LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU CENTER BATES.
SIR GROUP TO LIKE TO CHECK. SO
GET THE CHAIR JUST A SECOND TO
GET READY BUT NEXT UP IS SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY DOCTOR PETER. I
THINK LEISURE OKAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GROW FAST- MEMBERS- SB
ONE SEVENTY FIVE IS A RE WRITE
OF SB FIFTY ONE OF TWENTY
ELEVEN THE TWENTY ELEVEN
LEGISLATION PUT INTO CALIFORNIA
LAW THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
FORMAL CARE OF THE FOUR WHEEL
CARE ACT THAT HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS CANNOT HAVE LIFE TIMER
ANNUAL LIMITS ON THE HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IF YOU HAD A
SEVERE CONDITION LIKE CANCER OR
SOME OTHER YOU COULD ACTUALLY
RUN OUT OF YOUR BENEFITS AND-
THAN NOT HAVE- ANY FOR THE
COVERAGE. SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
REWRITES THE LAW TO REMOVE THE
FEDERAL CITATIONS AND SAID PUTS
THE ACTUAL FEDERAL LAW
PROVISIONS INTO CALIFORNIA LAW-
WITH- EFFORTS TO UNDO SOME OR
ALL OF THE ACA IT IS PRUDENT AT
THIS TIME TO INSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS TO
DATE- NOW ENJOY AND THOUGH THEY
HAVE CONTINUE HAVE ACCESS TO.
WHO ARE THESE VERY IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT. SO. SURE THAT WE
PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I DO HAVE
WITNESSES SUPPORT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CAN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DIANA DOUGLAS ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION WE ARE PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH WOULD CODIFY
INTO CALIFORNIA LAW. PROVISIONS
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THAT
PREVENTED PROHIBIT INDIVIDUAL
AND GROUP INSURANCE PLANS FROM
ESTABLISHING ANNUAL OR LIFETIME
LIMITS ON THE DOLLAR VALUE
BENEFITS FOR EACH ENROLLEE.
PRIOR TO THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT CONSUMERS ARE FACED WITH
DEVASTATING MEDICAL BILLS IF
THEY'RE KERIK CEDED THE BENEFIT
LIMIT SET BY THEIR INSURANCE
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE A NEW
PARENT AND HAD A BABY WHO MIGHT
REQUIRE COSTLY. WEEKS OR MONTHS
IN THE NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT OR IF YOU ARE EXPERIENCING
A SEVERE ILLNESS AND REQUIRED A
TRANSPLANT. HE IF YOU FIND
YOURSELF IN THOSE SITUATIONS
YOU MIGHT ALSO FIND THAT YOUR
COVERAGE RAN OUT JUST WHEN YOU
NEEDED IT MOST DESPITE BEING
INSURED. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE TOSE PROTECTIONS GAINED
UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
AND RETURN TO A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE FACING SERIOUS ILLNESSES
COULD BE LEFT ON THE HOOK FOR
THOUSANDS. OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO PROTECT
AGAINST FUTURE ATTACKS ON THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT BY THE
FEDERAL MINISTRATION OR COURTS
WE'VE CODIFIED MOST PROVISIONS
IN THE STATE LAW HOWEVER THIS
IS ONE REMAINING. THAT WE STILL
NEED TO TAKE ACTION ON SB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CONTENT CONTINUE
TO AFFORD THE CARE THEY NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST. WE
SUPPORT ONE SEVENTY FIVE AND
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER THAN
SUPPORT. AND FLORA ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR
BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND WITH
APOLOGIES FOR LATE LET LETTER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FINESCALE WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF O THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. EIGHTY ONE
REPRESENTING WORKING CAN BE
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU M.
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION. NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION AT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
CENTER LEYVA MOVES THE BILL NO
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS SIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. HER COLOR- THE
MOTION I APOLOGIZE SO THIS IS
TO PASS REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. PAN HI AND
I'D GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW HI
GROVE I HER TITLE THE TITLE I
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO.
SAVE SIX VOTES SEND YOUR BILL
IS OUT BUT YOU HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
BACK AND VOTE ON AND I'M SURE.
I THANK YOU. OKAY OUR LAST ITEM
IS- ACTUAL CONSENT CALENDAR WE
ONLY HAVE ONE ITEM. THAT SPACE
YOUR TWENTY EIGHT BY SUMMER
GIPSON ON SICKLE CELL DISEASE
AWARENESS MONTH IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL- SIX THREE PLEASE- THE
MOTION IS. THE ADOPTED REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS WELL.
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S
INTERESTING OKAY QUICK I THINK
THIS APPROPRIATIONS WILL DECIDE
WHETHER TO OFFICE OF THE ON THE
CONSENT COUNTER- THEIR CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT- SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CAN I AND
II GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROWTH
GROUP I HER TADO HER TITLE I
LEYVA LABOR AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY ACCEPT CALENDAR AS SIX
VOTES WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
AND ACTUALLY. DID NOT. BUT SHE
WAS HERE BUT SHE STAYED OFF
OKAY
. ALL RIGHT OF COURSE OKAY
SO WE ARE GOING TO- LIFT THE
CALL WILL START WITH THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IT'S BE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE- BY CENTER PAN MYSELF-
TICKET PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MONNING. MONNING
I RUBIO. ALL RIGHT SO- THAT
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO- NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX BY CENTER BATES-
CIRCLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT THE NUMBERS. MITCHELL NOW.
THE KERR VOTED NO. PASTOR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS MITCHELL. MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY SO THAT BILL FAILED ONE
FOUR AND- BARRING ANY
OBJECTIONS WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION OF NON THIS ONE
OKAY RIGHTS OKAY NO NO DESIRE
FOR RECONSIDERATION ON THIS ONE
SO IS THE SELF PAY THE BILL
FAILS- ONE FOR ONE FOR OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN FINALLY OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH ONLY
HAS ITEM NUMBER THREE ACR
TWENTY EIGHT BY A SUMMARY
GIPSON US SENATE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS
MONNING. MONNING AYE RUBIO.
OKAY DIXON TELLERS OUT SEVENS.
THANK YOU. YES SIR OKAY WITH
THAT- WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA OF THE THIS HEARING THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WE
ARE NOW ADJOURNED THANK YOU